[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: As the music
industry went digital,
the turntable seemed
destined for the scrap heap.
But this analog
technology defied
predictions and survived.
With a sound that's
arguably fuller and more
natural than compressed
digital formats,
this retro technology
is attracting new fans.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In an age when media players
are digitized and pocket-sized,
the turntable plays on.
The use of high tech
composites like carbon fiber
puts a modern spin
on this technology
bringing the record player
into the 21st century.
Production starts with a
thick square of cast acrylic.
The technician drills
a hole in the center.
It will be a reference point
as he transforms this square
into the turntable platter.
A computerized tool cuts a
circle shape out of the square.
The disk then spins while
another computer guided tool
enlarges the center
hole to size it
for the platters main bearing.
The next whole precisely
cuts the surface of the disk
to give it the correct angle.
Computerized tools transform
this small aluminum disk
into the counterweights
main component.
The counterweight balances the
tone arm to keep the stylus
in the groove of an LP.
They slope the surface and
cut holes for attachments
and for installing the part.
Finally, they cut a
triangle out of the circle.
This takes the part to its
final shape and weight,
from a flat disk to a precisely
crafted counterweight.
Next, the platform for
the tone arm takes shape.
It's designed to cradle all the
parts at the end of the tone
arm including a cylindrical
housing for a spring mechanism
and an egg-shaped housing
containing a bearing.
A technician now
assembles the tone arm
beginning with a tapered
to made of carbon fiber.
It's a high tech composite
that's extremely stiff.
So there should be no structural
weakness in this crucial part.
The technician threads
a pre-assembled wiring
loom through the arm to.
It's special wire for
high frequency transfer.
These wires have been
encased in copper
to keep out ambient radiation
that would interfere
with the tone arms operation.
The carbon fiber tube also
acts as a radiation shield.
He mixes epoxy resin that he
then dabs around the inner rim
of the bearing housing,
which has by now
been equipped with the bearing.
He inserts the tone arm
tube into the housing.
The tube adheres to
the glue-coated rim.
But before a totally
bonds, the technician
scrutinizes the alignment.
He makes adjustments if
needed, and then he'll
clamp the assembly to
allow the glue to cure.
With a turntable
tone arm now upright,
he solders the wires that
are protruding from the joint
to external wiring
for the amplifier.
And once all the
connections have been made,
he inserts the wires
into the metal joint.
Ensconced in this joint, the
connections are well protected
and can't be pulled apart.
He equips the main
counterweight component with two
thick steel beams for balance.
He slides the counterweight
onto a third beam,
which has been installed
in the egg-shaped housing.
This completes the
turntable tone arm.
Next, they encase the electric
motor and its metal housing
and they build the record deck.
They mount the motor to the
two-tiered deck designed
to absorb any vibration.
The aluminum
sub-chassis is next.
They link it to the motor
with the drive belt.
Then they give the belt drive
system a test spin to confirm
that it runs smoothly.
They now install
the acrylic platter,
felt mat, and tone arm.
With this turntable
now fully assembled,
it's time for the vinyl test.
The record spins and the
stylus traces the grooves.
The analog sound fills the
room proving this technology
stands the test of time.